hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today we are doing
another q a for another month in 2022
but 2021 i meant to say 2021 wow it's
happening this video is sponsored by
keeps we will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle but for now
let's get
to some questions lucas mckibben said
are your hands doing better
thank you for asking i feel like i'm
giving a lot of updates on these um
i mean you can still see you know the
bits that are pink oh it's really
disappearing on this one you can still
see bits of it um they definitely still
hurt and
the scars have like lumps inside of them
like this one has this big lump here
that's
very sore to touch um but yeah they're
doing great doing great
video games is hard because that is
stuff that presses up against my palms
but anything typing related is easy
i still don't have a ton of strength
when twisting things but
i'm doing just fine accident was three
weeks ago i'm sure i'd like another two
weeks
we'll be good to go even if it's not
quite how i wanted to start my year
we're doing okay thank you zachary
fantini said was there always a passion
of yours you had as a child that you
felt could have been a career of them
video games
my number one passion they are tied it's
not fair to say number one
but the answer is yes and it's writing
um i've written my whole life
my career really has been in writing
i just combine writing in video games
but when i was a kid i wanted to be the
editor of a magazine
so it was always going to be writing for
sure pravish binder asked what are your
thoughts on the
wall street gamestop situation eat the
rich
and jmv said any reason why the pwl
playlist is just titled video game
podcast
yes so the playlist for that on youtube
is just called video game podcast
uh intentionally so that if anyone wants
to go to my channel and find
my video game podcast that they have
heard of but maybe don't remember the
name of
it's under that playlist um because
obviously i upload a lot of different
stuff here
instead of just calling it play watch
listen because that name isn't
necessarily going to be immediately
recognizable to people who come to my
channel to know what it is so
i decided to rename it uh just so that
anyone who's looking at my channel who
sees playlists is like oh that's the
video game podcast rather than just
having it called play watch listen
because really that could be
any number of things pedro henrique
barrow said i have a question what
happened to your cyberpunk 2077 chair
do you still have it hashtag ask alana
um i've gotten this question about a
thousand times
genuinely about about a thousand it's
just
it's just wild um because
even when i had a different
chair or wasn't using the cyberpunk
chair for like the entire rest of the
year people didn't ask questions while i
have answered this question a number of
times
clearly i'm in the cyberpunk chair right
now um i'm just gonna
pose something to you that i hope will
be helpful for these kinds of things
going forward
if my chair is different and my headset
is different
and my microphone is different and the
lighting is different and the camera
angle is different
what do you think has happened have i
just swapped the chair out
have i thrown the cyberpunk chair in the
trash
like some of the conspiracy theories
suggest or if everything is different
every headphone microphone camera
lighting
could it be something else
could that be a different answer
for the question i think
you'll be able to figure it out i think
i i believe in you
that you will figure this out and again
there are totally other videos on my
channel where i don't have cyberpunk
chat
and have like all year because i'm in a
different place
i'm not at my apartment it's i'm at a
different location
okay that's that's the answer i didn't
throw a chair out
i'm just not at my apartment
it's so stupid but i guess while you're
here and asking about the chair
conspiracy i do have a video about
cyberpunk coming pretty soon
i didn't want to be the one to have to
make the videos hoping like someone in
media would because people are clearly
very confused about
one major part of it but yeah it takes a
lot longer to make
a video when i'm you know working the
kind of full-time job that i'm working
but i will have a video up
sometime in the next two weeks as soon
as i can get it actually fully made
max eisenberg said just finish night in
the woods and would love to hear your
thoughts on it
you know one of those games that
a lot of people i know love a lot of
people around me love and
i can't argue with that um but it never
did it for me
i i just couldn't get into it i'm the
same with stardew valley where i feel
like
those are two games that a lot of people
i know really like and always talk to me
about but i just
night in the woods just had this vibe
that i didn't really
[ __ ] with i i definitely wouldn't say i
dislike it it's just something that
didn't didn't click for me
michael hilton said when it comes to
gaming do you think it can play a role
to supporting positive mental health
in a similar way that fitness does a lot
of people across the globe turn to
gaming when they couldn't go outside due
to cover 19 and i think the future
studies on this will be interesting
uh i'm actually a board member on a
checkpoint i'm a board member on
a charity organization called checkpoint
which specifically focuses
on the mental health benefits of playing
video games and the relationship between
mental health and video games and kind
of
you know there are studies into what
games you can play if you have anxiety
and things like that the creator
uh jennifer is a doctor and does great
work
in that field um so i am a very strong
proponent and i feel like it's something
i've spoken about a million times
um of spreading the mental health
benefits of video games i think it's
it's huge and also really fascinating
you're right that that
i mean i'm so glad to have video games
during cobia i've played fall guys with
my sister i play among us with my
friends and basma phobia
and we've been playing red dead online i
don't know what i would do to socialize
without them because otherwise it's just
kind of zoom calls where you just sort
of
talk at each other and everyone asks the
same questions and it's just small talk
where i feel like playing video games
gives you actual genuine conversation
i don't know but definitely very
thankful personally and
something i really strongly believe in
oh hi can i interest you in talking
about
keeps for the next like roughly 60
seconds ish
do you know two out of three guys will
experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
and the best way to prevent hair loss is
to do something about it
while you still have hair left if you
want to no shame
love yourself but i am also very much in
support of you doing something to treat
yourself
if you feel insecure about it and one of
the coolest things about keeps is that
while you used to have to go to the
doctor's office for your hair loss
prescription now
thanks to keeps you can visit a doctor
online and get hair loss medication
delivered right to your home they make
it easy and deliver your medication
every three months so you can say
goodbye
to pharmacy checkout lines and awkward
doctor visits i do have a couple of
friends who've used keeps and
particularly
love that about them what i really love
about them is that they offer generic
versions of the only two fda approved
hair loss products out there
which is very important stuff so if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keeps.com alana pierce
or click the link in the description to
receive
50 off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash alana pierce that's me and
back to the video
pedro ramondi said are you liking your
new job are you making friends how are
you doing i absolutely
adore my job at santa monica studio i
love it making friends doing great
really really really love what i get to
do for a living and it's a very nice
feeling to just wake up every day and be
really excited or go to bed every day
and be really excited about
um about a job so that's all i can say i
did obviously get another
large batch of questions about the job
but i can't talk about it i will not
talk about it
that is something that is now totally
off limits but happy to say that i am
very very very happy
major insanity said have you stopped
making red lips orange car
uh ethan took a break um and was
honestly like it was just so hard for us
to schedule with all of the
anna stuff he's taking a break for a
month from making content and i'm sure
we'll figure it out when he gets back
but
it kind of had to be with the way that
we make that show that it had to be
flexible
um i'm sure we will continue making it
when we can but
yeah uh ethan's currently on a break and
i'm not gonna make him make my stupid
dumb podcast with me
while he's taking that break but yeah
hopefully we'll get back to it though
the show has not been canceled or
anything like that
richard loser said my daughter wants to
pursue working in the games industry and
looks up to women like you can you help
me be a cool dad and wish her happy
birthday her name is avery and she turns
13
this sunday happy birthday for this
sunday
avery please come work in the video game
industry
it's a fun place we'd really love to
have you here gonna write said what is a
piece of advice you would give to anyone
wishing
to become a content creator on youtube
um they said ps i love you so freaking
much and i think you were super talented
keep up the good work oh thank you
connor
this is really lame but the answer is
just make content uh i didn't set out to
become a content creator on youtube
i started my channel here um to try to
get
better at uh being on camera um because
i was already a journalist at the time i
was already right
obviously that is sort of my whole thing
and i
recognized that if i wanted to continue
to be being
employed as a writer in the games
industry that it would be really helpful
to have on camera experience so i didn't
have this giant gap
um when i recognized that that's where a
lot of the the sites seem to be heading
in the direction of and i just did it
you know i just started doing it um
you don't have to put that much thought
into it just make the kind of content
that you find fun
if you are just yourself i think you
will have more fun
be able to sustain it for longer because
you're not just in it for a following or
whatever else
and i think people will also probably
enjoy watching your content more because
it will be more genuine but
yeah the simplest advice is just make
stuff just make stuff that you want to
make that's it
spencer pennington said i remember you
posting on instagram back in august that
you just finished a book
given that you work full-time do charity
streams etc about how long did the
process take
uh it took me four years
to finish that particular book and then
nala thambi said what drives you to do
so much charity work
um look i never feel like i'm doing
enough i
am driven to my core
outside of the two things that i'm
passionate about which are video games
and
and writing and obviously i really love
learning just across the board but but i
think what drives me as a person is
helping people it's something that i
care about
tremendously uh something that i think
is extremely important
something that is sort of like a focus
that i have in life
is that i want to help people um charity
work never feels like enough like the
kind of stuff i do is just streaming and
trying to raise money and
you know i don't necessarily know what
all of the organizations that i've
raised a lot of money for are doing with
every cent that they have and then you
could criticize that but it feels like
something tangible that i can do
right now um while locked indoors
and there's certainly other things i
would like to do and more that i would
like to do
um and you know it can be really scary
because
people start praying on it uh as well um
i've had people with fake charities try
to trick me into working
for them but the main thing for me is
that i just feel like
carl sagan is just
one of my biggest heroes if not the
biggest
for being someone who became an expert
in a very complicated field
and could have just continued to do his
work in that field
but instead he translated his knowledge
and shared it with as many people as
possible
he he explored something to the fullest
became the expert himself
and then spoke to everyone else on terms
that a lot of people could understand
about the things that he had learned and
while i would think the the passion for
his field
being i guess astrophysics um
would have driven him to do all that
learning the
the thing that i think about all the
time is that he he took that time to
then
share that with everyone else and that
was unnecessary and i just feel like
that's so
important um and something that
definitely stuck with me
and something that i always want to do
and it's not like i have a field that
you know i certainly share all of the
knowledge that i have of my fields but
it's i don't have a field that that
that's as difficult to access
or that we have um a shortage of
speakers in
so i don't know it's a it's a for me uh
charity work is an overwhelming
compulsion and
it also just makes me feel really good
and i feel like makes other people feel
really good
you know and part of that's really
selfish so i don't think i would feel
fulfilled as a human unless i were
trying to do things like that
basically it looks like that is it
everyone thank you for watching today um
i can't find any more questions that i
have not already answered
so yeah thanks to keith for sponsoring
this video there will be a link in the
description below
if you want to ask questions for the
next video
uh leave them in the comments of this
one i basically just go back to the
previous video and that's where i pull
questions from
and otherwise i will see you guys next
month not because i won't upload for a
month but because that's when we do
another q a okay bye